What did the Romans do to democracy?
My friends,
what do they do?
They abolished it in favor of a
dictatorship.
Then the imperial system and why with
the word Raymond's not much good at
drama.
Why won't they?
Much interested in drama where the
tragic or comic,
but it's fundamentally the whole
audience was forever being dragged off
to another entertainment,
the games and watching people and
animals being smothered in a dupree
ritual that was endemic in the Roman
world and virtually absent from Greece.
How many people died in that building
that is emblematic still a raymond
culture and civilization.
The called the coliseum.
How many people were killed in it?
Probably 200,000.
The Greeks like the happy release of the
theater,
the Roman idea of good family
entertainment was cutting the feet of
some poor fif coating his stumps with
honey and letting the bas do the rest,
I'm afraid,
but in many ways the Romans were
Boston's
whipped and brutalized as children that
they'd like to inflict pain themselves.
What's the most famous image from all
the frescoes of pompey?
It's one of the women whipping each
other.
What happens?
Importance in terrorists instead of
jokes.
People hate to be float.
It was a society not based on democracy,
but on fear.